elle souffle ses 40 bougies cette année
et oui bon anniversaire à la fête de la
musique depuis 1982 et chaque 21 juin
elle fait danser les français
d'accord sur l'organisation d'une
journée pour la musique
[Musique]
à l'origine de cette manifestation
populaire deux hommes il yad'abord
maurice fleuret c'était le directeur de
la musique au ministère de la culture
dans les années 80 il y a cinq millions
de français qui font de la musique et
qui ne se sont peut-être jamais
rencontré qui ne sont peut-être jamais
écouté alors le 21 juin poussé musiciens
français amateurs ou professionnels sont
invités à descendre dans la rue à se
produire dans les parcs dans les jardins
sur le trottoir sur les places dans des
kiosques d'état ensuite jack lang à
l'époque il était ministre de la culture
est ce bien le rôle de l'état que
d'organiser de telles fait jusqu'ici
nous ni et ont guère habitués nous
n'organisons pas audi simplement libre à
chacun de témoigner par son instrument
de musique de sa joie à voir l'été
revenir mais vraiment il n'ya pas
d'obligation
21 juin 1982 jour de l'été c'est parti
la fête de la musique est lancée partout
en france la soirée commence mollement
l'ambiance a du mal à gagner les rues et
le temps n'est pas au rendez vous toute
façon je pense pas que les gens
qui descendent jamais ce soir
les musiciens de rue qui jouent dans la
rue si
les journalistes aussi sont sceptiques
cette gêne et des pros des za de rendez
vous manqués la fête de la musique
n'éclabousse pas encore la ville de
fraîcheur et d'imprévus reste une
mélodie balade pleine de charme et aussi
d'espoir
finalement après un démarrage poussif
l'ambiance gagne les rues dans la soirée
à paris nantes perpignan partout la
musique et péter
quelques croquis enregistré hier soir à
paris où on a chanté et dansé dans les
rues comme dans la plupart des villes
s'étaient bien souvent la fête de la
musique spontanée
quarante ans plus tard en 2022 la fête
de la musique s'est exporté dans le
monde entier
aujourd'hui elle est célébrée dans plus
de 350 villes et 120 pays
[Musique]